hallo leute hier wieder einmal waren und
willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender auspackt video
ich gebe ihm ein bisschen zeit um dieses
bild hier zu verarbeiten um dieses bild
zu verarbeiten um den ton hier zu
verarbeiten weiß ist es viel zu verdauen
aber ich dachte mir leid wenn ich schon
mal ein kameramann als freund habe frage
ich ihn einfach mal haye kann's mir
helfen das bild einzurichten eine stunde
später sitze ich jetzt hier mit einer
zweiten kamera und dem was ihr seht für
mich ist es ein bisschen ungewohnt aber
wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an und wir
ende und schon dran gewöhnen oder sehr
gut ich weiß nicht warum ich immer so
anti sein muss aber heute packen wir den
jetset globe adventskalender von
lifestyle aus
falls es nicht mitbekommen habt riesa
adventskalender aus so schwer zu
bekommen dass ich an dieser stelle sagen
dieses video ist nicht komplett
ungestört denn ich habe dreimal versucht
zum release dieser band kommen morgens
aufgestanden habe mir einen wecker
gestellt saß da und die sekunde und der
war immer weg und dann dachte ich setze
ich mal meine influenza power ein und
schreibt sie mal direkt an ob sie
million schicken können und wir haben ja
gesagt also das ist jetzt keine bezahlte
werbung ich habe den zum ausprobieren
zugeschickt bekommen und jetzt werden
vielleicht ein paar ausrasten ich darf
sogar einen zweiten verlosen
das heißt wenn ihr dieses video seht ist
auch instagram schon die verlosung
andere gegangen also wenn ihr unbedingt
diesen art kalender gewinnen wollte
schaute nach dem video auf instagram auf
meinem profil vorbei müsste ich die
ersten sein dass spielt gar keine rolle
und alle teilnahmebedingungen findet ihr
natürlich in der infobox danke danke
danke ich weiß ich bin die beste und
natürlich gar nicht weiterreden ein
ungeschminktes gesicht freut sich
einfach auf diese ganzen produkte die da
drin sind ich bin ein riesen koreanische
beautyprodukte fan falls ihr das schon
so ein bisschen wie mitbekommen habe ich
benutze sehr viele wasserspiele make up
produkte von koreanischen marken ich
weiß nicht warum aber seit ich sie
benutze ist meine haut einfach
hundertmal besser geworden und deswegen
schwierig so ein bisschen drauf es kann
natürlich placebo und einbildung sein
weil ich irgendwie korea mit beauty
verbinde und dadurch mehr vertrauen in
die produkte habe aber egal wir fangen
jetzt an dieser welt geändert 155 euro
gekostet also absolut nicht billig und
ich bin wirklich gespannt was sich darin
befindet gibt
oh mein gott eine sache zur verpackung
ich finde sie beautiful
das einzige was ich ein bisschen
ironisch finde es jetzt globe als motto
ich denke mal das war schon länger
geplant
aber gerade für 2020 ist travel thema
halt kompliziert so klappt man ihn auf
und er sieht einfach ja er sieht einfach
super gut aus das ist einfach ein
wunderschöner adventskalender und man
bezahlt auch 155 euro dafür also es
sollte er schon schön sein
ein türchen nummer eins befindet sich
fit bitte achtet nicht auf meine schere
die ist wirklich ein türchen nummer eins
befindet sich eins feigen saubermacht
creme ich trage jetzt kein make-up
deswegen kann ich das nicht benutzen
oh mein gott besonders kleine schaufel
einfach kalt hier irgendwas mit 7,8
prozent drin leider ist das auf
koreanisch alles geschrieben deswegen
keine ahnung was ich denke ist dass die
produkte nicht so unglaublich viel
kosten werden
die wird für 17 euro verkauft stabiler
preis und wunderschöner look to you know
me god die türchen sind so groß und die
produkte darin auch was amelia aromatik
revival russin fashion queen kremser
wieder was zum reinigen man leute mein
gewicht ist sauber aha also wieder ein
make up remover aber nicht zum
augenblick machen also wirklich nur für
dieses gesicht das ist eine sehr schöne
flasche die erinnert mich ein bisschen
an kylies kinder kostet zu den 21 euro
75 zweimal hintereinander etwas zum
make-up weg machen
was befindet sich ein türchen nummer
drei oder wie ich sagen würde komm ist
in asiatischen ländern so normal dass
man so gut einfach ist eine packung
kostet drei euro 29 x 5 also das sind
augen patches gut es macht eigentlich
schon sinn oder man hat jetzt erstmal
reinigungsgel bekommen also wer sind die
ersten tage und jetzt legt man die haut
herz und jetzt breche ich das herz wo es
ist ein gutes gefühl richtig kühlen aber
mit so einer scheiße kriegt man mich
auch noch was ich krass finde ist da
sind 33 schied drin ich könnte jetzt
theoretisch mein ganzes gesicht damit
volk leben das finde ich sehr gut
türchen nummer vier ist glaube ich echt
so sortiert irgendwas steht da drauf mit
augen
hier steht einfach absolut nicht was es
ist
in korea benutzen ja die frauen meistens
nur diese natürliche farbtöne weil sie
einfach ihre natürliche schönheit
hervorheben wollen und halt nicht so wie
in anderen ländern
also es gibt schon noch ausnahme war das
ist halt so die regel könnte man schon
sagen schon an mit der roten farbe wie
sehr puttrich ja absolut natürlich das
ist komplett meiner hautfarbe haben wir
noch hier das braun
aber weil es hat so einen durchgehenden
schimmer ich habe man sie zu wissen ich
bin mir noch nicht so sicher über diese
kamera das ist so eine richtige daily
pellet um einfach nur so ein bisschen
was zu machen sowas haben wir werden es
besser den augen
okay man kriegt eigentlich ein dreier
paar cruisen bestseller hat nur gute
bewertungen eine palette kostet somit
vier euro
ganz viele fragen nicht immer woher ich
dieses stirnband all das habe ich in new
york in einem koreanischen beauty laden
gekauft aber ich habe gehört dass gibt
es auch bei tedi genau das gleiche
mein leben okay wir machen weiter mit
türchen nummer bis jetzt muss ich mal
sagen ich kenne noch keine marke also es
sind alles neue produkte aber gut ich
kenne auch nur vier oder so was haben
wir hier professionelle skincare glaube
dass an der seite ist man so ein tipp
wie man sich so seine eigene maske noch
zusammenstellen kann
das ist hier aber jetzt eine maske wie
benutzt man die achter platz ist eine
maske man kann sie mit ampullen noch
pushen also ich mache jetzt drauf und
diese fünf bis zehn minuten auf meine
haut sein und dann muss ich sie ab
waschen und dann kann ich auch die
patches abmachen ich muss aber auch
sagen so sehr ich die koreanischen
beauty produkte und so feiere ich bin
froh dass ich nicht in so einem land
lebe was so oberflächlich ist also ich
glaube das ist dort schon echt eine ganz
andere hausnummer als bei uns hier nur
sagen bei uns werden langsam operationen
und irgendwelche gesichts optimierungen
werden ja auch immer normaler die maske
fühlt sich auf meinem gesicht richtig
gut aber ich merke nur dass es kühl ist
aber jetzt kein brennen oder jucken oder
irgendwas was konntest du professionelle
gesichtsmaske mit kostet 25 euro
türchen nummer sechs mal gucken ob sie
in korea auch nikolaus feiern
das ist unsere nächsten tierchen drin
ich weiß du nicht ganz genau was das
niveau
es sollen vibrieren ist aber auch öl ich
also zwei bis drei tropfen und es soll
bevor man sich ein creme benutzt werden
ich las eigentlich nicht so viel öl in
mein gesicht aber man sieht schön aus
konsum auf ich liebe es einfach
koreanische beautyprodukte kriegen mich
sofort ich bin doch vielleicht auch
nicht die beste bewährter was das angeht
aber das ist mein gesicht habt ja die
maske ist jetzt trocken meine maske ist
wirklich sehr trocken geworden wir sind
auch schon lange drauf wir ziehen jetzt
mal unsere süßen guten dinge abwarten
bevor ich mich abwaschen gehe ich mich
wie das kostet 33 grundlegender
wässriger öltropfen ich denke das nicht
ist es nun feuchtigkeit und wasser oder
dieses serum auf wasserbasis enthält
neben reis und seetang extrakten auch
grünes blatt wasser keramik peptide
sowie natrium juno und und hydra
aktiviert die haut intensiv verrechnet
die zentren sind die mich geben nach
vorne zieht schnell in die haut also
nicht kleben
ich gehe mal ganz kurz mein gesicht
waschen also ich kann euch sagen dass
wasser erlebnis ist ganz toll
also ich war schon ein gesicht auch
immer grundsätzlich mit so mikrofaser
hand ich fühle mich irgendwie drei
farbtöne heller aber das kann nicht sein
aber es hat vielleicht geräte bisschen
weggenommen jetzt geht es weiter mit
unserem wässrigen öl ganz normaler move
[Musik]
ok fühlt sich überhaupt nicht nötig an
dass kein stückchen also mein gesicht
fühlt sich einfach feucht an ich finds
gut nächstes türchen türchen nummer 7
sind nun schon und ich glaube das ist
megageil ihre deinen frühlings make up
look mit diesen lücken farben erhältlich
in fünf intensiven frühlingsfarben mit
einer wässrigen textur für ein
glänzendes finish sorgt was macht man
denn damit ich glaube dass titel glück
bestimmt ich bin jetzt ja wir machen den
mal drauf ich habe keine ahnung dass es
ist 8 eur 79 und mein gott ich liebe
leute ich sag mir bitte dass also das
ist vor allem man sieht kein bisschen
dass ich was auf den lippen hab ich habe
einfach nur gerade die lippenfarbe
verändert also wo hierüber gemalt habe
[Musik]
wir machen bei münchen nummer acht black
ice cream ich weiß nicht ob die
augencreme kennen dabei augencreme sonst
eine sehr kleine packungen das ist eine
sehr große packung hallo quito na gut
ich packe gerade ein adventskalender aus
ja
mercedes gefahren
naja leute ich muss leider abfertigt
rehn ich ruf dich in einer stunde an ja
was ist das schöne verpackung wow ich
hoffe es nimmt ein bisschen auch ich
weiß ja dass das aufnehmen kann
das hat einen hohen druck drauf okay sie
kostet nur 15 euro 95 wirkte irgendwie
gerade viel krasser die geruchsneutrale
augencreme wird mit extrakten aus papier
maulbeere fermentierte schwarzen tee
versetzt um die augenpartie falten und
feine linien zu reduzieren die creme ist
außerdem sheabutter magadan der
augencreme hat irgendwas befriedigend
bis gut und da augenpartie gerade ja ich
meine an die falten ist immer gut
natürlichen nummer 9
die stopfen die türchen haben auch die
frauen da echt rein 50 euro bezahlt oder
will man aus ist für kriegen also als
nächstes haben wir eine fußballs für
dienste ist sich bis 90 minuten wirken
soll perfekt ok wird das war meine füße
ich zeig euch nicht meine füße nicht
weil ich euch nicht vertraue aber es
gibt so ein paar menschen auf dieser
welt die füße einfach zu gerne mögen
meine füße haben das nicht verdient
jeder fuß für dich ist grades regiert
roman ich wollte ihre für das recht
aggressiv oder sieht ganz schön intents
aus und kriegt das einfach so und da
stecke ich jetzt meinen fuß rein so 60
bis 90 minuten okay also in einer stunde
fuß zum 82
super ich kann sich sein warum so
schlimm verlaufen ist glaube ich weiß
wie so häufig nicht so komplett im
wasser die sinne dass man auch drei
stück davon gekriegt hat ich habe auf
tik tok letztens gesehen dass man durch
so eine fuß maske also
sich so die ganze haut im fuß ab löst
also die ganze hornhaut ich wollte was
mit timo zusammen machen wir wollten
beide so eine fußmatte draufsetzen
kriegt er heute abend seine eigene eine
maske kostet fünf euro 95 x 38 10 euro
ok türchen nummer zählen da ist sie
beruhigungs creme okay was macht diese
beruhigungspille sensible ölige und
trockener haut die mediziner coming
cream beruhigt und generiert die haut
auf milder natürliche art glaube jeder
mensch auf dieser welt hat sensible
ölige haut trockene wenn ich warum aber
meine stirn ist irgendwie meine größte
sorge die creme ist gut wenn hauptsache
ich krieg auf nichts mehr reaktion und
natürlich immer elf war dieser gti
shadow drin den hab ich leider vergessen
auszupacken sorry türchen nummer zwei in
türchen nummer 12 befindet sich kollagen
curling fix sechs euro 30 king diese
dermatologisch getestete wimperntusche
wurde mit meeres kollagen formuliert und
um schwache wimpern mit nährstoffen
versorgt mit dieser wandel werden
schwache wimpern gestärkt also die ist
so fein
man kann bereich sich mal drüber gehen
passt aber zu diesem natürlichen look
den koreaner ja gerne mögen ich habe das
gefühl meine schwachen wimpern wurden
jetzt gestärkt so viel nummer xxii
klingel
die kann man benutzen um einzelne pickel
zu behandeln oder für die ganze haut
ganz dünn
ich hab eine lippe den können wir
behandeln so was damit passiert das
kostest du pickel creme schwere es ist
normal dieses gen wurde speziell für
unreine haut entwickelt und enthält drei
prozent kolonialen schwefel der für
seine antibakterielle wirkung bekannt
ist dass getroffenen überschüssigen teig
aus und versorgt die haut mit
feuchtigkeit und glätte das hautbild um
akten
haben und pigmentierung 'nen aufzuhellen
20 euro
diese anti pickel sachen dies die werden
diese trikotnummer 14 recovery diese zu
100% veganen pickel pflaster absorbieren
eiter und schützen die wunde mit
denn die haut gleichzeitig ok 51
pflaster sind da drin okay wer die
rückseite sieht es aber klar im vorteil
mittlerweile sind alle produkte entweder
vegan oder halt das s steht dass es
nicht an tieren getestet ist also ich
glaube da kann es ist man auf der
sicheren seite
ja das ist also so was habe ich noch nie
besessen so pickel pflaster super klasse
7 euro 19.06 nail also schnecken
produkte sind ja auch irgendwie was ich
typisch mit korea so verbinde schwarze
schnecken creme das anti aging serum
enthält 70 schwarz schnecken 70 schwarz
schnecken extrakt denn die spannkraft
der haut verbessert fünf schwarze
superfit sorten schwarze bohnen
schweizer reisst schwarzer sesam kennen
aber wieder so wie kann die exakten
glätteunfall so anti falten straffe haut
serum und sie kostet 13 euro
türchen nummer 16 ok jetzt sollen wir
hier irgendein chris paul auf das sieht
aus wie medikamente
das vielseitige zicker puder kann mit
anderen hautpflegeprodukten kombinierten
rötungen zu lindern und empfindliche
haut zu pflegen
die marke kenne ich die wundert sich
auch am 6 man soll entweder seinen
gesichts toner oder ein serum nehmen und
das noch auf die hand das drauf und dann
miteinander vermischen und dann hast du
noch mal extra gegen rötungen was ich
mein coole idee aber die umsetzung 10
euro türchen nummer 17
hier haben wir wieder kann dieser gelten
marketing längst leaping horse das heißt
ein drittel meinen sie damit aufhellen
oder einfach leuchtkraft allerdings gut
bewertet kostet 13 euro
ideal für trockene dunkle und unebene
haut bei sieht sich flecken habe aber
traum ich jetzt irgendwie auch nicht was
auf meiner haut zu machen was sie so
aufhellen sollte hier noch mal 18 und
schade dass ich nicht mehr so viel
benutzten kann weil ich ja jetzt quasi
mein gesicht gepflegt habe mit lipstick
müssen auch wirklich nicht darüber reden
ob dieser adventskalender seien
preiswert ist also da ist auch schon
wieder komplett übertrieben was sie
alles drin ist zwölf euro für diesen
liebste karl schöne farbe der halb matte
lippenstift lässt sich sanft und
ebenmäßig auf die lippen auftragen mit
einer hohen farbintensität ohne zu
verwischen
[Musik]
er macht halt war seinerzeit nur komisch
weil ich kein make up oder drauf hat und
jetzt halt wimperntusche lücken ist
ungewohnt eben ehrlich kirchen 19
jetzt kommen sie mit den lippen
produkten which any sechs euro 50 und
sehr oft gekauft und sehr gut bewertet
ich finde es ein bisschen der stranger
verpackung um ein gerade ski da sind ja
herzen drin gemeint ist habe ich rote
lippen und jetzt kann ich den lipsky
drauf machen also limperich das ließ der
jelly lipgloss enthält niedlichen
glitzer und gleitet sanft auf den lippen
um den make up zu perfektionieren
erhältlich in transparent oder in
berisha was hab ich hab' ich bin
natürlich hier nochmals 20 kommen
langsam dem ende zu das sieht ja
wunderschön aus 23 euro 5 die
hochwirksame essence besteht aus acht
arten von hyaluronsäure mum fertigkeiten
der stoffe findet dunkel strapaziert und
trockene haut zu spenden also das ist
ein feuchtigkeit boom boom macht ihr
noch mal extreme feuchtigkeit und gut
kommen bei gesichtsbehandlungen kriegt
man auch 30 millionen krems und sachen
aufs gesichtete york viel drauf
viel hilft viel glaube ich wird sich
auch wieder fantastisch an nicht kleben
ist es schon dass ein gutes gefühl noch
ein
weitere pflege 21 ich wollte echt ein
bisschen der mega sport kauder hieß wir
irgend so ein magic gibt es nicht also
man benutzt es direkt auf seine
problematischen areas folge sind was
anziehen die nummer 22
das wird wieder hier vollgestopft sieht
wieder aus wie keines kind eine maske
okay also probiert extreme es ist kommt
im film was jetzt ok den euro ist aber
nicht so gut bewertet also dreieinhalb
sterne das ist untypisch eine tuba sce
für sensible haut türchen nummer 23
schreiber mensch dreimal wäre doch gut
wenn man dann vielleicht doch noch
kriegen könnte es hat viele bewertungen
viele gute bewertungen 18 euro 42
das durch die zusammensetzung von roten
und blauen licht entstehen die violette
dominieren pigment erhält das gesicht
und definieren wenn sich züge rotes
licht lässt die haut heller erscheinen
während das blaulicht die haut sauber
und klar erscheinen lässt mit rot und
blau mit ihr gearbeitet okay
das sieht aus wie eine creme das hat
wirklich es hat wirklich so es hat
wirklich so ein rot blauen schimmer und
es riecht nach sonnencreme und ich habe
jetzt wirklich einen rot blauen schimmer
also genau wie bin ich jetzt auf jeden
fall
leute wir sind angekommen es ist
weihnachten
wir gehen zu unserem adventskalender
okay dass heiligabend wir gehen zu
unserem adventskalender und was finden
wieder drin etwas großes face control
lookbook jetzt lese ich euch eine kleine
weihnachtsgeschichte vor
das sind krasse farben
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet ich
glaube das sind highlighter ja blush und
vielleicht ein bisschen kultur ja ja ich
mein okay das ist halt universell
benutzbar make up in dieser
wirklich blöd weil dann werden andere
töne als superheld schon ausgeschlossen
und man hat eine eyeshadow pellet und
zwei lippenstifte das ist okay ich hätte
mir ein bisschen mehr majors gewünscht
muss ich sagen ich geh jetzt nochmal
meine fuß masken ab machen und dann
sehen wir uns zum feedback wieder ich
befinde mich vor meiner badewanne und
ziehe meine fuß masken ab es ist kühl
wird euch ja gerne meine füße zeigen
aber da gibt es gar nicht so viel zu
sehen wenn was passiert ich glaube das
wird sich jetzt erstmal ablösen
ich habe ein bisschen angst gehabt dass
seine rettung kommt oder irgendwas was
nicht so sein sollte aber hat aber zum
ende hin ein bisschen gejuckt vielleicht
finde ich die pace kontur ja noch
woanders dieser artikel ist momentan
ausverkauft gegen halb zwei schädlinge
gefunden ja ich sag mal so ich glaube
ich habe gerade 30 eur gesehen
30 euro jiechi mein fazit im
adventskalender ist natürlich ich liebe
koreanische beautyprodukte deswegen
liebe ich auf dieser bands kalender
ich hätte mir allerdings gewünscht dass
es nach diesen ganzen pflegeprodukten
mehr make up produkte gibt oder
vielleicht solche röhrchen so ein
bisschen spielkram aber wenn wir uns die
preis-leistung anschauen dann ja
man kriegt was für seinen preis ein
bisschen viel pflege aber vielleicht
auch gut für leute die sich damit noch
nicht so auskennen dass sie ein bisschen
produkte entdecken können und ihr denn
bitte an meine verlosung auf instagram
könnt ihr diesen adventskalender
gewinnen vielleicht für euch selber oder
für jemanden den er sehr gerne habt
schaut dort vorbei so heiß ich da und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
hoffentlich genauso professionell weil
ich glaube dass war ich ganz gut es sei
denn er fand es furchtbar schreibt mir
gerne eure meinung zu dem set hier auf
euch das gefällt und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten auspacken
da kommen jetzt noch ein paar bands kann
ich hab mal was für nägel dmp menge es
um nichts mehr
[Musik]